buongiorno controllo a tutti capite bene
che passare dall'astrofisica diplomazia
non è proprio una cosa banalissima però
ritorniamo con i piedi per terra abbiamo
volato in lontano perché anche come
farete un piccolo viaggio
spero come è stato detto io sono un
diplomatico di carriera ormai da molti
anni e ho avuto dopo tante sedi dopo
tante sedi all'estero
ho avuto una fortuna tornando a roma
cioè quella di essere destinato a
occuparmi ad essere il capo della
formazione dei giovani diplomatici
appena entrati il proposito di questo
devo dire che essere a bari o un puglia
ha un significato particolare per il
semplice fatto che ci sono molti
colleghi anche giovani prima lo
ricordavano che tengono proprio da
questa regione
bene perché formare i diplomatici
giovani è per me una grande sfida lo è
stata e anche un grande stimolo perché è
il modo per mettere trasmettere agli
altri quasi 30 anni di carriera ma
trasmetterlo sapendo che si passa questo
messaggio a chi farà questo mestiere
questa professione nei prossimi 40 anni
sapendo anche che lo faranno in
condizioni molto diverse da quelle che
ho conosciuto io che hanno conosciuto i
miei predecessori beh a questo punto vi
chiederete anche questo che cota e fare
con la resilienza perché questo è il
tema è appena iniziato ma sentiremo
sicuramente tantissima ti
interessantissime prospettive e visioni
abbiamo sentito la definizione io potrei
anche cavarmela brevemente se volessi
fare qualcosa di breve citandovi una una
classica frase che viene utilizzata in
vari contesti anche per i diplomatici
dicendovi che la diplomazia e la seconda
più antica professione al mondo sulla
prima naturalmente ognuno di voi può
farsi un'idea
in realtà in realtà è il noi viviamo in
un mondo sempre più veloce sempre più
rapido verrà fuori sicuramente in tante
altre occasioni non con i tempi che
abbiamo visto prima per l'astrofisica ma
è molto veloce
si parla ormai di mondo liquido questa
l'utilizzazione più più frequente quindi
in questo contesto
voi capite bene che certe volte anche
fra i giovani colleghi viene così un po
il dubbio ma noi in futuro cosa saremo
noi ci saranno i diplomatici in futuro
la diplomazia scomparirà mai è legittimo
avere tutto questo in realtà questo tipo
di di dubbio questo tipo di domandarsi
sul futuro ruolo non è qualcosa di nuovo
legata ad oggi perché se noi andiamo nel
passato
troveremo vari altri esempi ed infatti
questo è il viaggio in cui io vi voglio
portare un viaggio fra fra una serie di
profezie sbagliate che sono state fatte
nel passato circa la fine della
diplomazia e per fare questo
utilizzerò persone del passato e
citazioni cominciando dalla prima
questa è una frase esclamata dall'arpa
winston
intorno al 1860 lo pan stoner al
ministro degli affari esteri inglesi del
tempo che quando riceve il primo
telegramma telegrafo grande invenzione
comunicazione tutte le logiche
condizione cambiare dice mio dio questa
è la fine della diplomazia la formazione
molto forte una reazione decisamente
marcata probabilmente perché lo sponsor
che conosceva molto bene il
funzionamento della sua macchina della
diplomazia capisce che questa nuova
invenzione va a modificare
potenzialmente quella che è una delle
attività fondamentali svolta dal diploma
allora come oggi ve lo anticipo e cioè
quella di realizzare analisi e scrivere
rapporti questo è quello che cercano no
non solo ma i diplomatici di data come
dicevo è qualcosa di antico per questo e
tradizionale ed è molto radicato e qui è
un altro salto nel tempo
1560 andiamo ancora indietro poi poi
torniamo avanti e non è che andiamo solo
indietro non vi preoccupate 1560 questa
è una relazione c'è un documento scritto
da uno degli ambasciatori veneti
rilasciato di venezia nel 1560 madrid
lui era accreditato a madrid bellissima
sede penso allora come oggi molto ambita
sicuramente in cui scrive a venezia
descrivendo analizzando quella che è la
situazione nel paese
quindi questo e l'indice non potete e
dovete credere
l'indice prelazioni i vari aspetti
aspetto politico
l'aspetto militare l'aspetto sociale
l'aspetto commerciale
naturalmente quindi economico questo
interessava st un'attività appunto
diremmo oggi di reporting che è stata
per molti anni un monopolio un
oligopolio questo livello dei
diplomatici quando l'oms non è certo il
primo messaggio dice tutto questo
finisce non sarà più così in realtà poi
diciamo la messa in dubbio di questa di
questa funzione importantissima non è
solo avvenuta in tempi così remoti come
la seconda metà dell'ottocento di colpa
c'è qualcosa di anche di anche più più
recente che vi fa capire che è stata
notevolmente messa messa in questione è
stata messa in questione anche negli
anni 70 per esempio da pierre trudeau
pierre trudeau ministro degli affari
esteri canadese cosa dice negli anni 70
dice potrei rimpiazzare l'intero
ministero degli affari esteri con un
abbonamento al new york times io credo
che i miei colleghi canadesi del tempo
non siano stati particolarmente contenti
di avere un ministro che affermava
questo sta di fatto che questo tipo di
affermazione o d'immaginario si genera e
perché
non si capisce bene la differenza fra
giornalista diplomatico il lavoro svolto
da giornalisti al ruolo svolto dal
diplomatico hanno dei punti di contatto
sicuramente sono estremamente diversi
tra loro sono estremamente diversi in
insensibilità in tipo di notizia il
giornalista che cosa cerca cerca lo
scoop cerca la prima pagina quello il
punto risultato cerca la crisi perché è
quella che prova in prima pagina
diplomatico in questo senso è quasi al
contrario il suo compito è evitare le
crisi lavorare dietro le quinte quindi
lavora per non andare in prima pagina
non lui quanto quello che sta seguendo
quindi sono totalmente diverse e vi
posso assicurare che l'attività che noi
svolgiamo questi aspetti meno visibili
meno meno noti sono attività che ci che
ci prendono molto tempo e anche molto
molto impegno io spero anche con buoni
risultati ma non sta a me naturalmente
giudicare adesso vorrei parlare passare
ad un altro esempio di resilienza
collegato con l'attività diplomatica
diplomatici e questo riguarda
un'attività che forse almeno nel vostro
immaginario sarà abbastanza compresa
condivisa la convivialità ricevimenti i
pranzi ufficiali
tutto questo che il protocollo il
cerimoniale per capirci maggio vorrei
domandarvi se proprio su questo tema
questo è un po antica naturalmente però
suscita del dei pensieri
quanti di voi
quando sentono parlare di un diplomatico
di un ambasciatore o della diplomazia
come primo pensiero quello quasi
naturale quello che viene senza stare lì
a elaborare immediatamente pensare a
qualcosa del genere alzare la mano
alzata
non siate timidi per favore siete timidi
secondo me mi fa piacere vedere poche
mani alzate perché vuol dire che avete
una concezione reale di quella che è
l'attività che viene svolta in maniera
sostanziale dai diplomatici quale questo
tipo di attività è ancora molto
importante non è che viene svolta non è
l'attività principale un'attività
funzionale a quello che poi noi siamo
chiamati a fare quindi ad avere questo
tipo di di occasioni iniziative pranzi
cene ricevimenti a cui si va a piedi che
fanno male perché 1 st troppo tempo in
piedi col bicchiere in mano però è molto
importante che questo venga svolto
perché anche qui usiamo un termine che
ricomprende il concetto si fa networking
come si dice oggi quindi si fa rete si
conosco le persone si si fa conoscere
sia la possibilità per esempio quando si
è all'estero di rappresentare meglio il
paese per avere dei rapporti dei
rapporti diretti e bene anche questo
tipo di attività che comunque rimane
nell'immaginario collettivo è stata
messa in discussione è stata messa in
dubbio rispetto alla diplomazia
da chi adesso vi mostrerò che cosa ha
detto
il famoso scrittore è anche attore
inglese peter asti nof siamo fine anni
cinquanta afferma un diplomatico oggi è
niente di più di un capo cameriere al
quale permesso ogni tanto di sedersi a
tavola
ora per chi conosce se arriverà sino sa
che lui era anche un grande umorista
quindi naturalmente qui c'è anche tocco
di umorismo nell'interpretare un
cambiamento che effettivamente era
avvenuto nel ruolo dei diplomatici
oggi i primi ministri
i ministri degli esteri tutti gli altri
ministri hanno una proiezione
internazionale hanno tantissime
occasioni di vedersi direttamente con i
propri noris corrispettivi degli altri
paesi di di sentirsi frequentemente
direttamente quindi la necessità di un
intermediario
quale può essere un ambasciatore o un
diplomatico è decisamente diminuita però
c'è sempre un però
se voi esaminate attentamente i vertici
le conferenze internazionali le riunioni
internazionali le visite e vedete non so
le immagini delle visite le foto
noterete sempre un gruppo intorno a
queste persone a meno quando non si
parlano da soli in questo gruppo ci sono
sempre dei diplomatici c'è sempre
l'ambasciatore e non è un caso non ero
solo una questione di rappresentanza
naturalmente una questione di sostanza
ma sicuro che c'è anche se non li
riconoscete o meno riconosco i miei
colleghi quando li vedo in queste
occasioni e dicevo è questione di
sostanza perché chi è che
prepara organizza i vertici summit
riunioni internazionali
i diplomatici la preparazione prima di
incontrarci su tutto il lavoro di
preparazione lo potete ben immaginare
che è importante per la buona riuscita
poi di questo incontro sono i
diplomatici
chi è che poi si occupa dei seguiti dei
follow up come vengono chiamati di
quelle che delle cose che si sono dette
no magari anche separata sede
anche lì il ritorno a qualcosa di
conviviale i vari esponenti di governo i
diplomatici quindi capite bene che
questo ruolo
continua a essere molto importante
voglio mostrare un'altra foto in questo
viaggio che stiamo conducendo e andiamo
al 1961 1961 new york palazzo delle
nazioni palazzo di vetro onu riunione
chi siede nella delegazione italiana che
davanti e gaetano martino ex ministro
degli esteri
immediatamente dietro se guardate la
foto c'è una persona che sta
bisbigliando qualcosa si chiama su
showtime questo tipo di attività al
ministro che sta ascoltando con estrema
attenzione la persona che è lì dietro è
il rappresentante permanente dell'italia
alle nazioni unite del tempo
l'ambasciatore g di ortona uno dei
grandi ambasciatori e vedete italiani e
vedete
con quale attenzione viene seguito
quello che ha detto
ecco io credo questo sia uno di quei
casi in cui una foto come si dice
un'immagine vale più di mille parole
adesso ci avviamo alla conclusione e
anche per la conclusione se mi
permettete io utilizzare una una
citazione una citazione che me
particolarmente cara perché spiega un po
gli elementi che sono alla base di
questa capacità di adattamento della
diplomazia dei diplomatici ai mutamenti
che avvengono nel nell'ambiente nelle
relazioni internazionali nel mondo e che
contiene due elementi due elementi che
sono anche due mie passioni
la diplomazia mio lavoro ma che va ben
oltre naturalmente per chi lo fa lo sa
che poi va ben oltre il semplice
semplice professione e il jazz che la
mia musica preferita
allora che cosa ha detto richard brooks
richard holbrooke vice segretario di
stato statunitense rappresentante
permette alle nazioni degli stati uniti
2008 dice la diplomazia e come il jazz
un'informazione improvvisazione su un
tema perché io trovo che sia una
definizione straordinarie perché in
fondo riesce un po incapsulare contro
quelle che sono le capacità che anche un
diplomatico deve avere pensate all
improvvisazione jazz improvvisazione
jazz
quand'è che riesce bene primo chi la
esegue deve conoscere bene il tema su
cui improvvisa perché questo mi sembra
indispensabile poi ci vuole una grande
conoscenza tecnica ma per poter svolgere
di prodotti e poi ci vuole la creatività
ci vuole anche quelle
se no non va bene l'azione jazz e il
talento da solo non basta ci vogliono
questi elementi si ritrovano nei
diplomatici che ci aiutano un po a
comprendere perché nonostante tutte le
cassandre nel tempo tutte le profezie ne
abbiamo viste alcune che nel passare
degli anni si sono accumulati sulla fine
diplomazia si sono dimostrate sbagliate
è vero sicuramente che il ruolo dei
diplomatici molto cambiata non c'è
dubbio ma secondo me è più rilevante che
mai perché è sicuramente meno visibile
però continua a essere sempre essenziale
grazie